Çeviri: Ozge Yilmaz
Gözden geçirme: AHMET GÜRSU
Merhabalar. Yapay zeka kelimenin
tam anlamıyla yeni bir başlangıç tabii.
Düşünen yeni bir varlık türü ortaya
meydana getirmeye çalışıyoruz.
Aslında bu projeye başladığımızdan beri
bayağı da başarılar kazanmadık değil.
Satrancı insanlardan çok daha iyi
oynayabiliyor artık bilgisayarlar,
radyoloji görüntülerini insan doktorlardan
daha iyi değerlendirebiliyorlar.
Ama bugün bir konuda insanlar kadar,
hatta yani orta zekalı insanlar kadar bile
şimdiye kadar çok başarılı olamadığımız
bir yapay zeka alanından bahsedeceğim
İnsan dilini anlamak.
İnsanlarla sohbet etmek için hazırlanmış
şu sohbet botları, chatbotlar var ya.
onlarla ilgili şu facia haberi belki
duymuşsunuzdur.
2016 yılında Microsoft şirketi bir twitter
yapay zeka karakteri kurdu.
Bu insanlarla karşılıklı twitleşerek
onlardan insan dilinin inceliklerini
daha iyi öğrensin diye.
24 saat sonra da devreden çıkarmak
zorunda kaldı.
Çünkü bu karşılıklı yazıştığı insanlar
ona öyle fena şeyler söylemiş,
öyle küfürlü falan konuşmuş ki böyle işte
“Hitler çok iyiydi” filan diyen
mide bulandırıcı bir karakter
haline geldiği için devreden çıkardılar.
Hala da yok.
Bir sene sonra Çin’de belki
bunu duymamışsınızdır.
Çin'in sosyal medya platformlarından
kullanıcılarla tabiri caizse geyik yapmak
için hazırlanmış iki tane chat bot
işte yine benzer nedenlerden
“Benim hayattaki en büyük idealim
Amerika’ya göç etmek,
Bu Çin komünist partisinden
pek hoşlanmıyorum” gibi
laflar söyleyince hemen
devreden çıkarıldılar.
Bir kaç gün devre dışı kaldıktan sonra
tekrar devreye sokulduklarında yani
uslu konuşmaya başladılar
o konular geldiğinde.
Kusura bakma seni anlayamadım
tipinden yanıtlar vermeye başladılar.
Siri dijital asistanını kullananlar onun
arkasında büyük bir mühendislik başarısı
olduğunu bilirler. Ama şu da var.
Siri için her dilde edebiyatçılar istihdam
ediyorlar yani yazarlar şairler falan
istihdam ediyorlar ki böyle durumlarda
usturuplu cevaplar verebilsin diye.
Bir de anlamadığı zaman “kusura bakma ben
anlayamadım”dan ziyade,
konuyu saptırıp zeki olma yanılsamasını
sürdürecek şekilde
konuşmayı devam ettirmesi için
senaryolar yazmaya çalışıyorlar.
Daha Türkçesi çıkmadı onun Amazon’un
Alexa diye başka bir dijital asistanı var.
Bu Alexa’yı 20 dakika boyunca insanları
sıkmadan sosyal bir sohbet ettirebilecek
programcı ekibine verecekleri
1 milyon dolarlık bir ödül var.
Ve daha bunu alabilen çıkmadı.
Problem bilgisayarların insanların zaten
bildiği çok basit şeyleri bilmemeleri ve
bizim onlara bunu anlatmak için
bir yöntemimizin olması lazım.
Bu konu ile ilgili kendi başımdan
geçen bir şeyi anlatacağım.
Çok uzun yıllar önce
neredeyse 25 yıl olacak.
İlkokul üçüncü sınıf matematik ders kitabı
satın aldım bir tane kitapçıdan.
Onun içinden 20 tane rastgele
problem seçtim.
Ve bu problemleri bu türkçe aritmetik
problemlerini anlayıp çözecek
bir türkçe anlama programı
yazmak için kolları sıvadım.
Böylelikle Türkçe dil anlama konusunda
o zamana kadar girilmemiş bir seviyeye
gireceğim. Bir makalem daha olacak
filan diye düşünüyordum.
Programın adı ALİ.
Aritmetikçi Lisan İşleyici idi.
Şurda gördüğünüz tipten
problemler çözüyordu.
Bir fabrikada şu kadar işçi vardı.
Bu kadar işçi çıktı.
Bu kadar işçi emekli oldu.
Kaç kişi kalır?
Ya da törene şu kadar öğrenci bu okuldan
bu kadar öğrenci şu okuldan katıldı
Kaç öğrenci kalır filan gibi gayet basit
aritmetik gerektiren sorular çözüyordu.
Basit mi?
Siri'ye sorun bakalım
çözebiliyor mu bunları.
Yani şöyle söyleyeyim iki yılımı yedi ve
başlangıçta gayet güzel saçlarım vardı.
Öyle diyim.
Problem şu.
Mesela bu örnek üzerinden gidebiliriz.
Bir kamyonun deposunda
şu kadar litre mazot vardı.
Şöför bu kadar litre daha aldı.
Kamyonda kaç litre mazot olur?
Bütün bu türkçeyi analiz etmek için
gereken dil bilimsel kısımları geçtik.
İlk iki cümlenin sonucunda bir 212 litre
olması gerektiğini anladığı konuma gelelim
Orada şu noktaya gelebiliyoruz.
Kamyonun deposunda 212 litre mazot var.
Problemimizin son sorusu nedir?
Kamyondaki mazotun hepsi kaç litre olur?
Kamyonda kaç litre mazot var?
Bu bahsettiğimiz kadar bilgiyle
ALİ bunu cevaplayamıyordu.
Sebebini gördünüz mü?
Kamyonun deposuyla kamyon aynı şey değil.
Ve birinde birşey varsa öbüründe de
o şeyin olacağı bilgisi bilgisayarların
otomatik olarak bildiği bir şey değil.
Ve bu karışık birşey.
Ahmet’in babasının 5 çocuğu vardı
Ahmet’in de 5 çocuğu vardı
anlamına gelmiyor.
Ama kamyonun deposunda şu varsa
kamyonda da o var olması gerekiyor.
O yüzden insanların zaten sanki doğuştan
otomatik olarak bildiği bu bilgileri de
programa yazmak gerekiyordu.
Bunlara biz teknik olarak
sağ duyu bilgisi diyoruz.
Kamyonun deposu kamyonun bir parçasıdır.
Eğer A, B’nin bir parçasıysa,
değil mi?
B, A’nın içerisinde olan herşeyi içerir.
Bilgilerinin bunların hepsinin
yani esasen sağ duyu bilgisi
diye şuna diyoruz
iki insan karşılıklı konuşurken benim size
sizin zaten bildiğinizi varsaydığım için
söylemediğim şeylerin hepsi.
Malesef bilgisayarlar bunların hiçbirini
bilmediğinden işte o chatbotlarla
doğru dürüst konuşamıyoruz.
Bunların hepsini kodladıktan sonra
yirmi birinciye mecalim yetmedi.
ALİ bu 20 problemi doğru düzgün
çözebilir hale geldi.
Bu probleme sağduyu bilgisini
kodlama problemine
hayatını vermiş bir adamdan bahsedeceğim.
Douglas Lenat diye meşhur
bir Amerikali bilgisayar mühendisi.
Bu adamın 1980lerdeki hali.
Bu adam 1982ydi yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
CYC diye bi projeye başladı.
Proje aynen bu.
Bilgisayarların bu bilmediği sağduyu
bilgilerini teker teker kodlamak.
1 milyon satır gerekiyorsa
1 milyon satır yazacağız.
Bir şirket kurdu. Şöyle şeyler yapıyorlar.
Bir kahve içiyorsanız
bardağın açık tarafı yukarı bakıyordur.
Kral erkektir. Karısı bir kadın olmalı.
Karısına kraliçe denir.
Bir insan öldükten sonra
ertesi gün işe gidemez.
gibi insanların bildiği ve bilgisayarların
eğer insan konuşmalarını anlayacaklarsa
bilmeleri gereken şeyleri teker teker
kodlamaya çalışıyorlar.
Bu da adamın şimdiki hali.
Aradan 35 yıl geçti.
Proje hala devam ediyor.
Şimdi sanırım burada bi problem var.
Gördüğünüz gibi bunu elle kodlamada
bir sıkıntı olduğu ortada.
Şimdi olayın iyi tarafına geliyoruz.
Yapay zekada bir devrim yaşadık ve
artık bilgisayarlar bizim onlara
elle kodlayarak öğretmemize gerek duymadan
kendi kendilerine öğrenebiliyorlar.
Yapay öğrenme devrimi yaşandı.
Dil bilimcilerin şöyle bir fikri var.
Eğer 2 kelime birbiriyle tamamen
eş anlamlıysa çeşitli cümlelerde
onların çevrelerinde geçen kelime
toplulukları birbirlerine benzeyecektir.
Bu fikirden hareketle şu yapay zeka
araştırmacısı iseniz yakışıklı olmanız
için kel olmanızın gerekmediğini
gösteren adam Tomas Mikolov
Google’da çalışırken bundan
5 yıl önce şöyle bir proje yaptı.
Google’daki bütün İngilizce
dokümanları düşünün.
Anlatacağım örnek İngilizce
üzerinde yapılmış.
Bütün İngilizce dökümanları düşünün.
Her cümledeki her kelime için bu kelime
başka hangi kelimelerle birarada geçti
aynı cümlede geçti diye bir istatistik
yapacaksınız.
Akla gelebilecek bütün kelime çiftleri
için bunlar kaç defa birbirleriyle aynı
cümlede geçtiler kaç defa birbiriyle aynı
cümlede geçmediler
bilgisini bilgisayara saydırıyoruz.
Adı üstünde bilgisayar.
Bunu sayıp bu sayımları çıkartabiliyor.
Fikir şu ki iki kelime birbirine anlamca
birbirlerine yakınsa çevrelerinde
aynı kelimeler çok veya az
sıklıkta geçiyor
Mesela kedi kelimesinin de
köpek kelimesinin de
ne bileyim pire, kuduz, aşı, kuyruk,
yavru falan gibi başka kelimelerle
ortaklaşa yoğun derecede
aynı cümlelerde geçeceğini
ama printer, jeneratör, enflasyon,
filan gibi yavru kelimelerle
birlikte geçmeyeceğini görüyor muyuz?
Demek ki her kelime için öteki kelimeler
onun çevresinde kaç defa geçti tipinden
bir sayı dizisi oluşturabiliyoruz.
Bu sayı dizisine eğer Lise
müfredatından kaldırılmadıysa
sizin de bildiğiniz vektör diyoruz.
Bu vektörlerin yerleştirilebileceği
bir tür haritada bir tür uzayda
birbiriyle birbirine benzer sayı dizileri
yakın birbirlerine benzemeyenler uzak
olacak şekilde bilgisayar otomatik olarak
bir haritada yerleştirebiliyor.
Yani ne demek istiyorum.
Sonuçta bilgisayar hiç İngilizce bilmeyen
bilgisayar sadece bu sayım işini yaparak
her kelime için bir vektör oluşturuyor ve
Kedinin vektörü demin anlattığım nedenden
ötürü köpeğin vektörüne yakın bir yerde
çıkıyor o uzayda.
Ya da Harry Potter’ın gittiği
Hogwarts okulunun vektörü
gerçekten bu bakılmış bir şey
Vampir Avcısı Buffy’nin gittiği okulun
vektörünün yakınlarında bir yerde çıkıyor
Anlamca yakın çıkıyorlar.
Dahası var.
Lisede dersten hatırladığımız gibi
bu vektörlerin kendi içinde
bir aritmetiği yapılabiliyor.
Bunlar üzerinde toplama çıkarma
yapılabiliyor.
Bu ne işimize yarıyor.
Mikolov şunu keşfetti.
Bu şekilde öğrenilmiş vektörler üzerinde
şu toplama çıkarma işlemini yaptı.
Kral kelimesinin vektöründen erkek
kelimesinin vektörünü çıkarıp kadın
kelimesinin vektörünü ekleyince
kral erkek değil de kadın olsaydı
ne olurdu diye soruyor.
Tahmin edin hangi vektöre yakın çıkıyor?
Kraliçe.
Bu ilişkiyi Lenat ekibindeki gibi
kimse kodlamadı.
Bilgisayar sadece bizim yazdığımız
milyonlarca milyonlarca doküman üzerinde
kelime sayımı yaparak bunu keşfetti.
Dahası var. Bu gerçekten oldu.
Türkiye bilgisi var orda.
Paris kelimesinden Fransayı çıkartıp
Türkiye'yi eklerseniz
Evet tahmin ettiğiniz gibi Ankara çıkıyor.
Yani bu vektör uzayında ülkelerin
isimlerinden başkentlerin isimlerine
giden bir yön var. Acayip birşey.
Windows, Microsoft tarafından yapılmamış
olsaydı da Google tarafından yapılmış
olsaydı ne olurdu diye sorduğunuzda
Android çıkıyor.
CU’dan bakırı çıkarır yerine altını
eklersek altın elementinin kısaltması olan
AU çıkıyor.
Yani resmen bu bizim elle
kodlamamıza gerek yok
Sanki bütün o saçtığımız bilgiler
içerisinde bilgisayar bunları
kendi kendine çıkarsayabiliyor.
En güzel, en leziz örnek bu.
Sushi’den Japonyayı çıkartıp Almanyayı
eklerseniz Almanların sevdiği
bir sosis var ya o çıkıyor.
Çok iyi.
Mutlu muyuz?
Artık bu projeyi gerçekleştirdik
Bilgisayarlar bizim ne dediğimizi artık
anlayacak mı?
Neşeli miyiz? Çok değil.
Şimdi size bir Türk araştırmacıdan
bahsedeceğim.
Amerika'da doktorasını bitirmek üzere olan
Tolga Bölükbaşı diye bir arkadaşımız.
Boston Üniversitesinde.
Onun 2 sene önce yaptığı bir araştırma.
Tolga bu Mikolov’ın yaptığı şeyin aynısını
sadece haber metinleri üzerinde yaptı.
Doktordan babayı çıkarıp anneyi
yerine koyarsak ne çıkıyor?
“Benim babam doktor annem hemşire.”
Bilgisayar programcısından cinsiyetini
değiştirirsek daha doğrusu erkeği çıkartıp
aslında bir cinsiyetinin olmaması lazım
tabi yerine kadını koyarsak
Yani bilgisayarın kafasında oluşan o anlam
uzayında acaba bu meslekler birbirine
cinsiyet nasıl ilintirilmiş bilin bakalım.
Ev hanımı çıkıyor.
Resmen ev hanımı çıkıyor.
Homemaker diye bu anlama gelen
bir İngilizce kelime var o çıkıyor.
Bilgimizi sadece vermekle kalmamışız
bilgisayarlara.
Aynı zamanda kendilerine bütün
önyargılarımızı da vermişiz.
Şimdi bu bilgisayarın birisini işe almak
için kullanılacağını düşünün.
Otomatik olarak siz verilerinizi
özgeçmişinizi yerleştirdiniz.
Tabi orada cinsiyetiniz filan
herşeyiniz de var.
Ve diyelim on bin kişi başvurdu.
Bilgisayar önce bir eleme
yapacak değil mi?
İnsan kaynakları personeli insanların
analiz edeceği
diyelim bin kişiye indirecek.
9 bin kişiyi kendisi eleyecek.
Hali hazırda bilgisayarlar bu gibi
işler için kullanılıyor.
Bu şekilde anlam vektörleri yüklenmiş
bir bilgisayar, bilgisayar programcılığı
işine başvuran insanları...
bilgisayar programcısı dediğin
erkek olur
bilgisine sahip olduğu için otomatik
olarak kadınları eleyebilir mesela.
Aynı şey Tolganın makalesinde
onlar da var.
Zenciler ve beyazlarla ilgili kelimeler
aslında onlarla ilgisi olması gerekmeyen
olumlu veya olumsuz çeşitli fiiller
ya da işlerle ilgili
mesela soyguncu daha çok zencilerden
çıkıyor buradaki hesaba göre.
Bilgisayar böyle olduğunu düşünüyor.
Bilgisayara sadece bilgilerimizi vermekle
kalmadık bütün önyargılarımızı da
kazandırdık.
Simdi ne olacak diye düşünebilirsiniz.
Ama tolgaların makalesinin bununla
ilgili bir de çözümü var.
Az önce de bahsetmiştim.
Bütün bu olaylar bir vektör
uzayında oluyor.
Her kelimenin bir vektörü var.
Gerçekten liseden biliyoruz ki biz
bunları birbirine ekleyip çıkarabiliyoruz.
Tolga ve ekibi gerçekten erkeklikle ve
dişilikle ilgisi olması gereken kelimeleri
önce bir listeliyor.
Mesela baba, dayı, büyükanne falan
bunların gerçekten erkek ve
dişi rolleriyle
ilişkileri olması gerekiyor.
Ama ondan sonra bir de bilgisayarın
belleğinde erkek ve dişiye yakın çıkan
ama öyle olmaması gereken kelimeler var.
Gördük. Ya da mesela dahi kelimesi
çok erkek bir kelime olarak çıkıyor.
Ama stilist kelimesi çok kadın bir kelime
olarak çıkıyor.
Bunların böyle olması gerekmiyor.
O yüzden Tolgalar oturmuş.
Gerçekten erkek veya kadın olması gereken
kelimelerin listesini elle hazırladıktan
sonra geri kalanların yani cinsiyetten
bağımsız olması gerekenlerin hakkındaki
bilgisayarın önyargısını otomatik olarak
silecek bir algoritma gerçekleştirmiş.
Eğer bu listenin içinde değilseniz yani
baba amca falan gibi bir kelime değilseniz
ve hali hazırda anlam uzayında
belli bir yöne
doğru sapmış durumdaysanız
Tolga'ların algoritması bunu
otomatik olarak düzeltiyor.
Bu çalıştıktan sonra bilgisayar
programcısı erkek ve kadına
aynı mesafede oluyor.
Demin dediğim sıkıntı yaşanmıyor.
Güzel di mi?
Keşke insan beyninde de önyargıları
silmek böyle kolay bir şey olsa.
Uzun süredir kimi insanlar eyvah
bilgisayarlar yönetimi ele alırsa
halimiz nice olur diye soruyorlar.
Öte yandan insanlardan silinmesi zor olan
bu şeyi bilgisayarlardan silip onları
gerçekten tarafsız hale getirebildiğimiz
için belki de hakikaten hakimleri,
hakemleri, tarafsızlık gerektiren yönetici
pozisyonlarındaki insanları
bir dinlendirip bilgisayarlara burada bir
fırsat versek fena olmaz diye düşünüyorum
Ne dersiniz? Sağ olun.